the rejects it's Greg here it's John so
uh Greg and Sean today what Greg and
John are gonna do is we're gonna talk
about who we think could play the next
Joker
oh boy in the DC Cinematic Universe for
DC EU people have been speculating that
Jay Leno might be fired from being the
joke some people are assuming he's
probably out of the picture at this
point in regardless whether he isn't it
or isn't I still think he could be
replaced I have an idea that is one you
have to hear me out on when I go into it
John I feel has a couple of people in
mind the heat that I think would
definitely be more likely to see happen
but I have one that I'm kind of treating
like as if it was a movie fights
question and I went with my answer
here's how I would pitch it you've got a
very distinct answer I got like a few
suggestions I think could work normally
we have like a you know a photo green
screen in the background but here's the
truth I'm kind of liking my raggedy
clothes today and it's all green this is
green - who does not have a body for
this one I know John and then I have to
pull the couch out and I have to pin the
green screen against the wall then I
have to end then I have to like do the
whole green screen it's just an extra
like hour and a half of unnecessary
things the third video it's gonna get
like what a few thousand views only a
few thousand people yeah well well you
know contree it with better quality yeah
my pronounce more water it really works
moving the couch for me like it really
dawn the green screen takes time than
the exporting called me dawn dawns on
you boss give you're a couple choices
first oh yeah we think actually play the
Joker and came up with a few ideas I
started mulling mulling them over and I
was like well who I cast is a young guy
who would I cast is like a respected
actor who would be my wild card so I
came up with a couple ideas the top two
that that sort of seemed the most likely
to mirror or that could like they could
do it the most to me were um Hugh Dancy
and Ben Foster I think could definitely
do it cuz Ben Foster I know I know you
really clicked with me when I when I
mentioned Ben Foster earlier and I think
he's a guy who has proven he's a good
enough actor who can bring in the diff
mannerisms and really throw himself into
a role and you know he seems like a very
dimensional actor that could totally
that's my go-to but way he puffed out
his chest and it's like really smoldered
and his father he's not so huge that
he's like the likely choice but he is a
guy whose name you kind of know now and
who is a great you know solid actor and
he is proven he's great at playing
villains he's great at playing like very
different kind of villains like he
changes up the mannerisms the voice he's
a young actor too yeah so you get like a
young actor who's great at doing like
method it kind of acting yeah yeah yeah
like we're talking jared leto
replacement i feel like he would be a
good one someone who could so bring
something unique but not be so far
different from Jared Leto that you're
like this is kind of confusing for my
little mind in the universe right yeah
and that's sort of why I touched on Hugh
Dancy - he's on Hannibal and stuff like
that and that's a guy who it seems like
you know can throw himself into just
about whatever I think Hugh Dancy could
do in Joker and that would be a chance
to see him in a more sort of wacky fun
way or Joe Anderson I thought might be
another good one who's Joe Anderson did
you see the crazies yeah and the horns
yeah okay
he's the the deputy and the crazies and
he's Daniel Radcliffe's brother in horns
oh yeah he looks like Jared Leto yeah
kinda he's got that sort of those of
those narrow wiry features yeah oh yeah
I could see we like the makeup on how he
could totally off the Joker and he's
another guy who I think is just a
terrific actor and like he's one I can
fleet could totally have fun with it and
is good at taking on mannerisms I really
like and then I thought of some just
some wild cards really clear if you're
going like Ben Affleck and you want to
stage like a similar type of actor
against him I I thought Jake Gyllenhaal
might be cool for that but especially
after seeing stuff like Nightcrawler
think he could make you know maybe an
interesting Joker Johnny I said your
pitches you sound way too relaxed I'm
sorry I'm way too casual I'm gonna leave
the fire of you you lose movie fights
if you part of it is passion if I got on
TV I would throw it in we got the
creativity down but where's the passion
John you're just too nonchalant it's
like yeah I could go with either of
these choices that's where you're gonna
lose this round
there's no fight that movie fight
approach I really feel like I'm already
attacking my rationale or it's my choice
about everything cut you off in any
moment my choice I do feel you got to
hear me out on this one I would go with
Mark Hamill now as a lot of you know
Mark Hamill is the defining animated
voice of the Joker he's done the
animated series he's done some of the
animated movies he's done a lot of the
games as well
he is the defining voice of the Joker
now here's why I would choose Mark
Hamill I feel like okay it might be a
little weird sure if you were just the
throw in an older Joker like in the
middle of what they're kind of trying to
establish but let's face some facts here
Jared Leto and Suicide Squad was a big
letdown for a lot of people I don't care
about your argument about whether or not
you we saw enough of him or whatever at
the end of the day he was a
disappointment for a lot of people he
was barely in it special we don't really
need to strongly hold up this mantle of
Jared Leto as the Joker he's only gonna
be like 10 or 15 minutes if anything you
know one DC sin enough of an earthquake
that I feel that people would have
braced just about any it was it's better
it was yeah exactly I feel like people
could get on board for Mark Hamill for a
couple of reasons one yes the obvious
one would be that he already proved that
he can do the voice of the Joker in a
totally different kind of way to he's
already an established as a it's a
pretty good actor he's coming back with
Star Wars Episode a where he's supposed
to have a much more predominant role so
he is gonna be in the public eye again
yeah maybe Mark Hamill got a little
heavy over the years but I feel like any
actor could lose weight if they pay him
enough money or get him a personal
trainer you know you could lose weight
to be the Joker another reason why I
think it'd be totally cool to have an
older Joker is it just didn't make sense
to me why they got Jared Leto in the
first place because they just said
they're going for an older Batman if you
look at Batman V Superman he is an older
Batman and they even established that
you know the whole incident with Jason
Todd took place where they have this
suit like the joke's on you spray
painted on it if it's honoring the
timeline
the comics that went Dick Grayson and
then Jason taught him by that time you
know Dick Grayson was probably Nightwing
already so this is a much older Batman
and then in Suicide Squad I'm like why
is he a young Joker then it should be it
older Joker someone who's matched with
like the age of Batman at that time and
I feel like who better else to play an
older Joker than Mark Hamill himself
another great thing too is if you watch
footage of Mark Hamill in the booth when
he's doing the recording a lot of times
voice actors can just do the voices he
does the voice but he also changes his
body language up his facial expressions
when you see mark become the Joker when
he's actually in the recording booth and
doing these voices he actually
physically kind of twists himself and
manifests himself into Joker and a lot
of that does transfer into his portrayal
of the trickster on the flash TV shows
regardless though I think fans would
absolutely love it because we love him
as the voice of the Joker it would be a
perfect excuse to show why he's an older
Joker and another thing too is like this
would be a chance for fans to see him do
it as a live performance not just the
voice when we already love him so much
as the voice a lot of times people ask
who's your favorite Joker
people will say Mark Hamill I mean if
you want if you get really specific you
narrow down with the movies most people
say Heath Ledger but if people go for
like overall scope even for Batman
people say Kevin Conroy
so for Joker a lot of people say Mark
Hamill and I really feel like that would
be a great way to give DC fans some
great fanservice and give them something
new and an excuse to give us something
that we've all kind of wanted to see
which is a live portrayal of the Joker
from an actor who's not uncomfortable
being in front of the camera boom but in
movie fights Andy what does the Twitter
poll say on that fact check his back
checking that one Dan Jack Nicholson was
at least a stocky joke wouldn't have to
drop that much I remember when you first
pitched that to me I was like wow I'm
convinced I know it sounds a little
weird when you first yeah Mark Hamill
it's a leap it is a leap and it's
drastically different if you're just
going with the continuity timeline of
Suicide Squad I really don't think
people will give a [ __ ] if you just
break that
because it's like who's really gonna be
upset over how [ __ ] impactful Jared
Leto's Joker sure those Joker's you just
doesn't [ __ ] matter
like he doesn't matter so might as well
give us a brand new Joker and so you
know Heath Ledger was a young actor in
someone who was like you know people
were unsure if he could do it but then
he do so let's get your let him know
because he's kind of like a new Heath
Ledger oh that's totally different
choice this time and yeah give us
something that is different
challenging daring at the same time you
know meaning halfway with fanservice I
can see the change not being a big deal
to cuz looking good cuz it's not even
just about Jared Leto you know I get the
sense that a good number of people don't
like that take on the Joker now look an
attitude also yeah I feel like DC is in
a fortunate point now or if they want to
make some changes it's like you know
Marvel did this with a Hulk they want to
make some changes they probably can yeah
and that would be like you got me
excited to see that movie it's good to
be honest I'll be cool yeah are you
really cool yeah I feel like Mark Allen
would do an excellent job we already
know he can do an excellent job you just
throw some makeup on him he'll be fine
yeah he doesn't have to drop that much
weight yes you can just establish some
[ __ ] of like you know Suicide Squad
takes place in earlier time yeah I mean
you're gonna have to regular Harley
Quinn thing that would be the tricky
part is justifying that against Harley
Quinn cuz there's no way they're gonna
lose Margot Robbie
alright rejects who would you cast to
play the new Joker what did you think of
our choices Oh Jason Momoa yeah perfect
you know me that'd be crazy with a beard
system big old Viking Joker Joker
Stanley Tucci mark Strong who I
sometimes mistake for Stanley subscribe
button here John is on Instagram and
Twitter links in the description box and
he also social media manages blue Mouse
and real rejects Facebook page and shout
out to Sid Wilder I might be collabing
with youtuber Syd Wilder she's really
popular on social media such as
Instagram come on comedian slash model
she is
a talented I've seen a few of her
sketches actually she's really [ __ ]
funny I would love to be in one of her
sketches and she said that she wants to
collab with me because she thinks that I
am the cutest guy on YouTube it's
possible you might have been cuter than
Flik pic she said oh man
cuter than Jeremy John's she only
watches movie reviews are you cuter than
Stockman no one's cuter than Stockman
yeah I know
except for me obviously but not cuter
than harloff no no no we're anyone I
collide her no Collider has their own
colliders like a bunch of good-looking
people who talk about movies it's not a
real nerd site you're all too
good-looking to be nerds Hey seen kidnap
suck we're like kidnapped [ __ ] I don't
know why just kind of rise a [ __ ] this
is my shadow to sit Wow